[Música]
hola vamos a hacer un ejercicio de
percepción
vamos a hablar acerca de una fruta muy
específica créanme delicioso que no se
imaginan cómo es el google tan hello
es impresionante
y vamos a ver cómo votan ustedes
con respecto a cuál parece más apetitosa
con respecto a cuál es menos fea
esta foto en un tan hello
observen lo bien color de donde es
etcétera
el siguiente
primo definitivamente viene al mismo
lugar
vean lo bien
y vean ahora la anterior
por favor levanten la mano aquellos de
ustedes o aquellas de ustedes
que creen que esta se ve más bonita más
apetitosa
ok
esto
jugado
cuáles de ustedes también son totalmente
indiferentes
ok bien no voy a poder contar manos
definitivamente pero la respuesta es muy
ambigua
hay demasiada indiferencia verdad
pero por eso es que uno no se explica
porque esta foto que tiene un tanque lo
que yo cogí de un desperdicio en el sur
del perú en el departamento de ica
departamento desértico porque nunca
llegó al estante de un supermercado en
países de exportación y esta otra
fotografía la tomé más o menos unos seis
meses después en un supermercado de alta
gama en washington dice
hay un problema de fondo resulta ser que
ésta nunca llegó a estantes de
supermercados no por razones
fitosanitarias
porque tuviera algún problema de plagas
ni nada por el estilo simplemente porque
alguien la evaluó bajo una sierra y
estándares cosméticos estéticos y dijo
esta es fea
no tiene el tamaño adecuado no tienen la
redondez a adecuada la coronita de
arriba no es tan bonita o el anaranjado
no no no no no calza con el anaranjado
que el supermercado nos pone aquí
parece una cuestión menor
parece una cuestión de calidad
pero cuando gracias al trabajo que me ha
tocado hacer para entender el por qué
será esta serie
imperfecciones de mercado también me
topo con que el resultado de muchas de
esas decisiones de forma continua
terminan en algo así
no se preocupen no tiene que contar hay
mil toneladas
en una sola planta empacadora en el sur
del perú y créanme que visitamos varias
de estas con magnitudes relativamente
similares
de nuevo este tipo de decisiones
multipliquen las por cada uno de los
países muchos de los cuales estamos aquí
representados multiplíquenlo por los
cultivos frescos sobre todo que existen
y que se desarrollan y muchos de los
países que estamos aquí representados y
créanme ahí sí estamos hablando de una
magnitud que llega a las 1.300.000
toneladas sólo el producto fresco a
nivel global por año de desperdicio
producto de este tipo de estándares de
calidad
gracias a mi trabajo en la investigar en
la organización que represento hemos
podido en conjunto con otras
organizaciones de países desarrollados
tratar de ir al campo y entender tanto
de la mano de productores como empresas
exportadoras porque cuál es la dinámica
que genera estas magnitudes de
desperdicio y cuáles son los principales
impactos que muchas veces ellos
solamente dan por sentado como una
cuestión más del mercado es así como
entonces en guatemala hemos podido ver
desperdicio de productos frescos en
algunos productos muy poco tradicionales
como las arvejas en varias variedades el
ejote que es mucho más tradicional el
brócoli productos insignia el desarrollo
agroindustrial reciente en costa rica
como la piña por supuesto y el banano
era una manera más tradicional y también
por ende en perú el espárrago cosechado
totalmente en las dunas del desierto
sobre todo en el sur del perú y otros
productos también muy importantes como
las uvas
todas estas mandarinas tangelos como las
del ejercicio que ustedes me ayudaron a
completar
al principio verdad
y nos vamos dando cuenta de que esto
tiene una dimensión ambiental
importantísima mucho más allá de lo que
se refleja de manera muy tangible
por ejemplo en este campo de cebolla
totalmente tirado ahí en el perú sino
que por ejemplo si sumáramos las
emisiones de dióxido de carbono
equivalente de un país que se llamará
desperdicio de alimentos frescos
estaríamos hablando del tercer país más
emisor del mundo
y no solo es en términos de cambio
climático o en términos de emisiones por
diferentes fuentes
hay un desperdicio enorme en términos de
agua en términos de recursos suelo en
términos de agroquímicos etcétera que
resta de luego no solo al desempeño
ambiental y la sostenibilidad de estas
regiones sino también a la
competitividad de la cadena de valor que
está aguas abajo en este segmento de
exportación solo a nivel de productos
frescos
esto representa en los países en
desarrollo 310 mil millones de dólares
por año
yo creo que eso es más del pib del mucho
de nuestro país de cultos
y todo esto sin olvidarnos de una parte
que a mí me parece a veces hasta
grotesca
en productos frescos entre el 35 y el 45
por ciento del trabajo de esta gente se
va a la basura
qué sentirían ustedes si más o menos de
usted sabe de plano que casi la mitad
del trabajo suyo va a ir a parar de
nuevo al campo
para parar de nuevo a un vertedero oa
irse a sepultar debajo de las dunas de
un desierto bueno pues eso les pasa a
gente como estas señoras que están
cortando espárragos
en el sobre el perú entonces hay una
dimensión humana muy fuerte
a la que hay que entrarle y que es muy
evidente
por suerte en muchos países en
desarrollo y una serie de organizaciones
que están haciendo esto cambiar que
están tratando de incidir tanto en
consumidores finales como en
supermercados para que este tipo de
estándares estéticos y restricciones
vayan cambiando poco a poco
por ejemplo en esa imagen ustedes pueden
ver como chefs sumamente reconocidos
están cocinando todo un banquete para
5000 personas en el festival de cannes
en francia a base de productos
qué quiere decir es posible sin embargo
el problema es que esto está cambiando a
un ritmo que es relativamente lento en
comparación a la magnitud de los
impactos que acabamos de observar
entonces hay algo más que hacer y algo
más que hacer y muchos de quienes
estamos aquí quienes hemos tenido el
privilegio de pasar por estas aulas o de
tener una educación diferenciada tenemos
que hacer algo hay que dar un paso
adelante
en muchos lados esto sería feo pero
bueno a mí me parece que ejemplifica
mucho ese tipo de acción que tenemos que
tomar y que es lo más interesante que
paradójicamente muchas de las
herramientas que en un lugar como encaje
se ven algunas de las tiene un principio
a nosotros nos parecen relativamente
básicas créanme muchos de estos
productores muchos de estos experta
dores todavía no las conocen o no las
implementan cosas que de repente en
algunas industrias más sofisticadas que
algunos nos han parecido atractivas como
investment banking componer un nombre
sexy
puede que no tengan tanto impacto pero
créanme que algunas de ellas pueden ser
brutalmente diferenciadoras en contextos
de desperdicio como los que estamos
viendo algunos de ustedes estarán un
poco familiarizados con imágenes como
esta operación eso uno dirían algunos
por acá
la forma de calcular mediante una
distribución probabilística una cantidad
óptima de pedido generar una razón
crítica fácil parece que no genera tanto
valor definitivamente calcular esto aquí
no va a generar nada más por decir algo
pero créanme que esto haría la
diferencia de miles de toneladas en
contextos como los que ustedes acaban de
observar y que nosotros hemos estado
investigando y por qué no pensemos un
poquito más allá y veamos cómo entonces
nuestras capacidades pueden también
servir para la generación o la
optimización de una serie de modelos de
negocio que con base en una dinámica de
mercado pueden perfectamente generar un
emprendimiento social que a su vez venga
a resolver problemas de desarrollo en
regiones muy específicas ya mí me gusta
mucho el caso de la de la encup harina
en guatemala que es una bebida
energética muy nutricional desarrollada
más o menos hace 50 años en este país
con base en uno de los elementos más
autóctonos de la gastronomía
guatemalteca el maíz
pero resulta que cuando uno va al
altiplano guatemalteco esta gente no
está solo cosechando maíz esta gente
está cosechando arvejas que cuando las
preguntas que hacen con el 40% que botan
te dicen no la sabemos cocinar la arveja
está riquísima en hierro por ejemplo
bueno porque entonces no aprovechamos
estas capacidades que muchos de nosotros
hemos ido adquiriendo acá
de repente puede hacer puede surgir una
nueva incaparina con base en todo ese
montón y toneladas de toneladas de
arveja que se están desperdiciando hay
oportunidad hay una necesidad y créanme
hay muchas otras industrias donde
podemos ligar lo que nos apasiona en lo
que nos hemos formado para solucionar
una serie de problemas de desarrollo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]